the man who brought Adrian Peterson to
this team in a trade with this is the
New Orleans Saints is the general
manager Steve calm kind enough to call
in on game day how are you there Steve
red time don't get rumour Rumour and
Phoenix is you're in the bubble lounge
it is true I am in the bubble lounge
here in University of Phoenix Stadium
it's very swanky it is a very very
swanky room here I don't know if you
remember the time we were in LA and I
got you that glass of expensive wine but
yes mr. bid was extremely generous and
any came a silver oak or anything else
you see that you would be excited about
feel free to to order up
oh well when you what do you mean by
order you're saying the one that I've
already because I already have my
carry-on bags for the flight home here
[Music]
are you saying fantastic
all right let's talk about the
acquisition of Adrian Peterson story
true story that you were pounding the
table for him in a draft room in 2007
for the Cardinals to bring him to the
desert well I mean listen I mean he was
certainly a guy I like to come about as
you know in the draft process it's such
an exact science and and it's one of
those things that you look back and if I
told you all the guys I've known it's a
humbling process and it's one of those
things that you know yeah I certainly am
excited to have him now you know two out
of the three games he's rushed for over
100 yards he's been a huge addition for
us and he certainly made it on offense
well how did that all go down with with
Adrian were you were you just monitoring
the situation that the minute that you
learned that David Johnson was going to
be out for the foreseeable future
we did you know it was one of those
things rich could you no supers David
Johnson went down and you know it's one
of those situations you can't replace a
guy who basically accounts for 2,000
yards of your offense but you know to be
able to find a guy of his caliber and
and and coach and I had talked at length
about you know adding adding somebody
like Adrian that can
and bolster this offense can can create
some balance I was able to get a deal
done with with mickey loomis and talk to
Sean paid their length on the day that
we traded for him and the one thing I'll
say is those guys were so professional
and I was very very appreciative of the
fact that not only did did were they
easy to work with but they wanted the
best for Adrian and they knew that he
would certainly fit what we do and it's
been we've had success with him all
right and is it true he is in fact
living in Larry Fitzgerald's guesthouse
right now said is that a fact but it's
probably so big that I don't even know
if Larry knows sort of like Larry David
is what you're saying life it's Joe like
Larry David like that yeah there's no
doubt there's no doubt or the place that
you live in Brentwood right nice try
though very nice try sir
I appreciate the effort on that front
what can you tell us about David
Johnson's readiness to return the play
in 2017 Steve you know he's one of those
guys it's a he's he's a fast healer he's
a genetic specimen he has worked
extremely hard in the process to come
back but at the end of the day that the
bottom line is is you know you have to
wait for some of these injuries to heal
on the surface and and again you know
our doctors our trainers have done such
a good job he has to play with you know
a cast and and that sort of thing so we
just want to make sure that moving
forward that he's healthy he's ready to
go and and we certainly don't do
anything with a cold it's gonna you know
hurt his career for the long term sure
but as we're sitting here getting ready
to kick off week 10 it's still it's
there's still a shot at this happening
you think yeah I mean you know there's
certainly a shot that guys like him TJ
Logan who was on our IR Carson Palmer
guys that could potentially come back as
I are to return players the thing you
have to do from a league standpoint is
you have to designate those players six
weeks and then they plant you know can
play eight weeks
so you have to have them after you
designate them they have to practice for
two weeks with the injury and then you
know obviously from an injury standpoint
they can play and that's a good thing
because it's making sure that these guys
are ready to go and there's no issues
moving forward and what about Carson
Palmer what can you tell me about him
mm-hmm you know he's he's been around
every day he's certainly involved he's
keeping his mind sharp I know that in a
meetings if being allowed the team you
know he's the consummate pro and the one
thing that I respect about him whatever
is his not only his mental toughness
rich but the thing that I don't know if
anybody gives them enough respectful was
physical toughness it he has I think the
guy is going through a lot in his career
and uh I don't know if there's any
player that's tough with a cost of
course all that and he's poised to
return whether that happens or not is a
different story
but but but again a lot of respect for
him Steve calm general manager of the
Arizona Cardinals here on the Rich Eisen
show there's a draft board for next year
exists somewhere in this building that
we're sitting in right now it's not in
that building but in our tempering
office there's okay there's certainly a
you know a draft board it's it's
changing every day
you know our scouts did a fantastic job
Terry McDonagh new principal on our
personnel department you know they're
outstanding and you know it's one of
those things that it's constantly
evolving and today's day and age as you
know rich it's one thing to look at the
seniors that are out there but once
those juniors and and an underclass
would declare for the draft that's what
the board completely changes and those
guys are generally the majority of the
top one or two rounds where have you
visited what college football have you
seen this year Steve Conte email rich if
I if I told you I would tip in my hand
so I can't get there yet how many
college football games have you
purchased don't tell me where how many
college football games have you
personally I bought this should have
been through eight of them but again if
I told you it'd have to kill you
nobody tell me to do any do any of the
places rhyme with ish again for instance
any any any other flavored with odor
game any places that absolutely and I'll
tell you what um you know we have so
many Michigan guys in our building alone
you know Larry foot Hale Goodwin our
offensive coordinator so I hear I have
to hear about Michigan every day you
know Notre Dame is one of those places
unfortunately my alma mater went up
there a couple weeks ago NC State I
thought they would give him a little bit
better of a game but turnovers called us
and a Notre Dame prevailed but you've
seen eight college football games this
year yeah and you know a good thing
about it is nowadays you go into your
game on Thursday night see game on
Saturday you know that's the part about
the business you can never you know when
you get in this position you know you
feel like the evaluation process is what
got your here and then there's so many
different things that happen whether
it's contracts and and dealing with
players and staff numbers that take you
away from it but you know you constantly
have to remind yourself to be successful
that's what got you here and that's what
really matters in terms of the success
of building a 53 man roster yes I guess
the last one for you is is technically
obviously anything can happen but is
your I guess work for with the trade
deadline having been passed you'll work
for the 2017 season essentially done
Steve like yeah I mean I know you know
it's one of those things that were
constantly working on our ready list you
know working a futures contracts you
know if there's injuries you know we
obviously have to address that but you
know for the most part you know we're
playing with the guys that got us here
and then and and again edition with
Adrian Peterson we signed Alex Boone
right for the season started and there's
guys who can continually help you and
get you better but but yeah exactly now
I mean now we're starting to turn a
little bit of attention to not only
future contracts but the draft and
gentlemen would making sure they were
prepared for that okay and and Aryans I
mean what can you tell me about him
because he you know it seems that's just
every every month he's got to reiterate
that he still likes doing the job and he
still has the the desire to do it being
around him Steve what can you tell me
about your coach and his and his
stamina for the lack of a better phrase
yeah I mean I think it's one of those
things rich and you know coach well I
mean he's he has made my job not only
extremely easy but he's made it fun and
this job's hard enough and he comes to
work every day with a smile he keeps it
live as you know and he has a special
gift when dealing with players not only
the ability how to coach him hard but
love them later and and and and and
that's one thing that I think to me gets
lost in this business you know it's it's
it's easy to be hard on players but to
be able to gain their respect and the
trust and their love you know it's a
special gift and Bruce is one a few to
me that has it and as long as he's
having fun I think we'll continue to
coach and from what I can see he's still
having a lot of fun good luck tonight
Steve I'll see you out there and and and
just tell me where you're gonna be
watching the game and whatever bottle of
wine that you want me to snag here or
the Fivefinger discount from the bubble
will be a michael bittersweet but I'll
try to get there only enough rich to
meet you fantastic we'll see you soon
Steve thank you okay my friend take care
okay
right back at you Steve Conte for more
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Rich
Eisen show app